alors jeudi dernier tf1 diffusée
exceptionnellement collante alors je ne
sais pas si c'est à cause de balances
ton post que l'audience a
considérablement chuté par rapport au
premier épisode 3,7 millions de
téléspectateurs ils ont perdu en une
semaine près de 2 millions de
téléspectateurs et 10 points en pda
c'est très rare voilà c'est le plus
ferme le score sur les moins de 50 ans
aussi et deuxième plus bas de son
histoire sur l'ensemble du public
ce que l'on regarde encore koh lanta
plus du tout bryan n'ont pu tous brahim
moi non pas du tout c'est ce que j'ai vu
que je vois koh lanta pour vous c'est
trop facile quoique l'on tarde pas quand
on off des lentilles des trucs et à
quelque chose mais rien est à rien et
supporte les caméras là c'est beaucoup
c'est pas pareil vous trouvez que koh
lanta c'est maintenant c'est c'est trop
facile quoi sert alors je vous le dis
pourquoi pourquoi ça a baissé
vous allez nous dire j'aime j'aime pas
et vous avez une bonne et les
explications alors si l'émission vous
avez dit pour certains que l'émission
était maintenant faisait trop penser à
un programme de télé-réalité y en a qui
nous ont dit ça qu'ils pensent à qui
voulait un réagir là-dessus oui oui moi
je trouve que koh lanta c'était une
belle émission d' aventure qui a perdu
complètement son adn
on glisse tranquillement vers une
émission télé réalité c'est plus tf1
c'est fx
on est dans la villa des cas brisé alors
chacun est libre d'aimer ou pas mais
c'est pas l'adn de koh lanta et là je
suis désolé moi jouer non qui c'est qui
a trouvé poisson acquis allumer le feu
c'est un trush on retrouve un petit peu
hypocrite de la table parce que la
semaine dernière mais a tendance à nous
perdre 5 millions et quelques voiles à
5,1 millions 6 tout le monde et mais
aujourd'hui je ne crois plus tellement
annonce j'aime plus que c'est bon c'est
les mecs son nom et quand on a des amis
comme on a pas besoin d alors on va
regarder un premier extrait avec victor
que candidat qui fait le plus parler en
ce moment c'est un candidat qui a
tendance à beaucoup ce sera une petite
copine mais je vous le dis vous êtes un
petit peu mauvaise foi même vous vous
adoriez maintenant vous n'aimez pas
perdu deux millions alors attention
intel metois la danse je vais vous dire
qu'on va voir
le fait d'avoir réussi le feu ça a
redonné du baume au coeur et un grand
sourire à toute mon équipe vous fait la
concrétisation de la technique j'avais
apprises
concernant puis ça a payé réaction était
un peu étrange c'est à dire que il est
ce besoin impératif de sa tribu je
saurai toujours faire payer aux gens
leurs failles et leurs faiblesses pour
prouver ma ma supériorité mois et on le
dit tout le temps ici j'aime pas
l'hypocrisie
kelly elle elle me dit en off laquelle
était complètement d'accord avec moi
c'est hypocrite
ben alors là c'est complètement dingue
du retour de koh lanta ça me manquait
j'étais hyper contente et le premier
numéro j'étais très contente de
retrouver
j'étais très contente des trois équipes
et gt line dessalage très de à aimer
l'histoire des poteaux en début
d'émission en revanche parce qu'il m'a
tuer ce qui m'a gêné sur le la deuxième
émission c'est le fait que maintenant
alors quand on perd on peut revenir
il ya une par exemple les routes et les
retours sont toujours perdus et dont on
sait en plus sans spoil qu'en fait ils
vont revenir mais qu'en fait ils ont
perdu mais pas vraiment moi ça ça m'a
chagriné et que vous savez on a cet
extrait vidéo prochainement vont devoir
élire un nouveau chef
moi tout un chef
débuta sont à même pas les mêmes parce
que tes mauvaises cloud est de toute
façon pas un mauvais fond le camp rouge
est complètement désunie
qui sera le nouveau chef des rouges
tensions en perspective surveillait
l'échangé d'un simple
écoute théâtre victor revient dans la
danse motivé comme jamais je vais y
aller
[Applaudissements]